the Joe Rogan experience it's true like
there's la as an epidemic homeless
people right now where there's so many
tents on the street a napa [ __ ] endemic
but they're everywhere I mean [ __ ]
Lancashire yeah you're not doing there
in Sherman Oaks
yeah the streets are hiding on the
underpass underpasses are stuffed with
them now some you know I mean we have to
fail what are you gonna do it you can't
walk through those under water do you
know what the answer is you know what
they usually do with them they give them
a hundred bucks make them a bus pass to
Vegas and now Vegas is stuck with that
we talked about that on the pockets a
lot every city's done every city keeps
to like [ __ ] it's time to get [ __ ]
some a park and put a tent city and make
him be resourceful okay water hazard in
10,000 empty rental units in Los Angeles
fill in those spaces won't solve the
housing or the homeless cries yeah but
the problem is if these [ __ ] things
are for rent and you have these homeless
people that are drug addicts and
probably mentally insane and you let
them stay in those rental apartment
they're gonna destroy your rental place
well let's be honest there's 110,000
whoa whoa whoa it all depends on what
kind of homeless person you're talking
right now you're talking about a person
who's down on his luck are you talking
about mental illness mental illness drug
addiction yeah that stuff I definitely
well I see 60 when I see a hundred when
I see 10,000 homeless people in LA I got
to assume 4,000 of them our people were
down there look at minute they got four
flat tires and it just kept you know
this time as people go through [ __ ] for
periods of time it could be here yeah it
could be it's like these [ __ ] hikers
every [ __ ] three days a hiker gets
lost okay yes hikers gets lost and they
stroll off when they get saved they're
all happy you see my eye witness news
I'm happy wait till they get the bill
they get hit with a bill oh yeah every
time most widows have a couple of claws
so they volunteer if every [ __ ] hiker
got paid for for a [ __ ] taxpayer we'd
be broke so like in Colorado so if
you're one of those hikers it goes and
snaps her ankle
and you're on Ridge somewhere they come
and get you i cost somebody money you
got to pay somebody there's no [ __ ]
tax funds does that cost whoa that's a
lot of me you get hit listen if you'd
like lady who got stuck in Hawaii for a
week where the [ __ ] she was a month ago
those helicopters cost something she's
stuck in Hawaii a little lady the lady
teacher the girl yeah you know they
found her right yeah they found I assume
I'm just saying the story just because
what happens to something like that
happens see and you get hit you ever get
involved in a lawsuit okay in a lawsuit
i rear-end John Rogan Joe Rogan's neck
and the god forbid his neck and his back
to hurt he can't do God's right you file
a claim against me hmm why you're going
to the doctor right all those months
what is the doctor usually rate there
yet everything's payable at 30 days net
30 is it mm-hmm
when you start getting those 11 hundred
dollar bills from when they look in your
knee and in your neck when you get 10 of
those how you gonna pay them cuz you
can't pant you get the settlement from
their [ __ ] attorney
mmm a lot of times people go broke by
the time they get the money to ship your
sale takes seven years to get that money
you've been going to the doctor for
three is rate the insurance covers all
this money's yours
well tell everybody within that car is
just theirs it's more complicated what's
that
tell everybody with the neck collars oh
yeah more complicated yeah
so all those bills add up you get hit
with a bunch of bills Joe you're
homeless
yep you're homeless you're telling your
wife whatever its homeless unless you
have parents and yeah you know you're
homeless and you're not so well I look
at the homeless situation when you hit
me with a 50,000 number which is a lie
if you go around that way it's a while
and at the airport and hook that [ __ ]
thing up to the four or five north and
look under that there's a hundred people
just under there mm-hmm so whatever
number they tell you what do you think
they tell you as far as like homeless
population they're not know I I don't
know I know Garcetti is under fire like
I know that [ __ ] yeah like the people of
West because they gave two million
dollars well he can't really knows they
gave him money and he didn't do dick
oh right yeah they gave me some type of
money you got to put up some shelters I
saw the up in North Hollywood Studios
there's a church then on Thursdays they
go and take showers there
[Applause]